congratulations on how this films been
received so far thank you very much
just wonderful thank you and worthy
interested to know who you who did you
set out to make the film for good
question I felt as though it was perhaps
I would say this it was for everyone in
as much as when I told people that I was
perhaps going to do the film I felt I
got a tremendous reaction from lots and
lots of grown-ups as well as every kind
of variety of man woman and child that
made me feel that the story was very
personal to people and whatever their
age they might have seen or doll read or
currently have read to them an account
of the story and that in a strange way
although people have talked about the
fact that it's been done many times
there seems to be a sort of ritual in
that that's necessary anyway for
whatever level whether it was people
saying is gus-gus in the movie which
they were very keen to know about and
how many parents are going to die that
kind of question and just sort of you
know what was the period and everything
that the kind of level of interest was
high and it's a personal sense of this
story and the importance of the story
made me feel we could do it for everyone
for without without sort of alienating
folks so that's the way I went at it
Richard
never mind it'd been every girl's dream
to play a princess you've done it done
the princess take that one off the list
Rick its royalty done yeah I didn't
really think about wanting to be a
prince to kids but play soldiers and
he's one of them so I kind of focused on
that there's an amazing tone in the film
and which I guess it's time to do a lot
of different factors but the scenes in
particular with you and and your
on-screen father it was just a lovely
warmth Thea that feels very very natural
and was that was that scripted was the
rizona element of you been able to
improvise at all with with Derek Derek
or we did a little bit of them for
didn't--we I think that's what was good
about bringing out the the kind of sense
of humor between them and I mean I just
loved working with dead
he's wonderful and and we had fun with
it and that was part of what we wanted
to do is kind of make sure that these
two had a sense of humor and I think
particularly I wanted to take my sense
of humor from My Father so it was great
the delek was so good and warm and funny
as well because I could feed off it
specifically there was a moment in the
scene in the in the when they first meet
where that little repetition of yes I
would know you wouldn't yes it would no
you wouldn't and at that kind of thing
and then when we got to the scene with
Littleton and rich on the swing I think
was your idea to kick or you I can
remember one of these two very brilliant
people came up the idea of why don't we
do that as a kind of call back and it
you were talking about tone and it was
it was allowing as much room for these
tiny things they're tiny things but
cumulatively they make for a sort of a
human texture and and they were all onto
it very swiftly and Sundy
congratulations
I mean wow I mean a costume designers
dream I imagine having or was it because
there's there's so many images that
people already have in their head
associated with the Cinderella story
did you kind of take that and run with
it or where did you start I have been
saying that it's a costume designers
dream as really is yeah it really is
it's what I think was thrilling for me
was actually it's a film about girls
where a lot of the main characters of
government okay there are the boy
characters too but really predominantly
women which doesn't happen that often
and I just come straight from the wolf
of Wall Street which couldn't be
so yeah I just it was it was a dream and
I just yeah as he said I ran with it
alle morning to you and congratulations
on the casting of this as well in terms
of and I don't know when the one
similarly with what I assigned in the
sense that there is so much the
characters already have so much attached
to them because everyone knows the story
did that make it easier for you or
harder in terms of of kind of Carson and
where you started with that well I would
say that I would turn to the director
because we were certainly very aware
that these characters brought with them
great our title histories but Ken's
approach to this movie was always about
mining a complex psychology for all of
these characters and really looking into
the depth and to expand their stories
based on those kind of emotional
explorations so I can't imagine it was
ever easy but I will say that Ken
definitely had very clear ideas for
casting and we were always very much in
sync because we're all so much a part of
the conversation about who these
characters are and David if I can bring
you in place in terms of this the the
notion that the story is still relevant
it's a story that's people still want to
hear and they want to hear people's you
know adaptations and thoughts on it
that was very work we can mention to me
that some Disney been in touch about a
live-action version of Cinderella I said
oh interesting yeah how do we how do we
do something that's not you know she
doesn't have a sword now and she's not
decapitating the the stepmother how do
we do something that feels relevant for
a contemporary audience and is in its
own way from a faithful to the other
masochistic and Ken had he's very good
salesman for a stop action so within
about 15 minutes other was a great idea
but he had a very clear vision about how
how to make how to make this film that's
all for today and it was this has this
central message of courage and kindness
it just seemed that
if he pulled it off which he did it
would work for today in work first
consumer audience thank you holiday
amazing partnership and this kind of
crazy you're kind of one piece of this
crazy to piece puzzle of these these two
characters and that must have been a lot
of fun to bring to life did you enjoy
that that kind of yeah you know kind of
fighting with each other or that kind of
that pool that you both had with each
other it really was fun so I mean as an
actor you so he's quite often quite some
incident in your characters was great
for the first time to be part of a
double act and can really want to kind
of play off that of that idea it was
speed running the lines and fading like
finishing each other's sentences and
yeah so I think I spent a lot of time
together during filming so I feel like
by the end we were literally were
finishing Lily congratulations an
amazing wonderful portrayal of
Cinderella I wanted to ask you a few was
any qualities in the character that you
worthy connected with there was a
breakdown of the character and there was
just this line that said that she had a
generosity of spirit and I just thought
just sort of that felt like that's
something I've sort of as a kid my dad
would even say those words and and I and
I felt like it just spoke to me and I
wanted that idea of this character
having such warmth and such an open
heart and and and she lives in the
moment she sees the good and all these
qualities that are amazing yeah I guess
you always have to draw from yourself
and channel your character through
yourself great thank you
what's your audience chairman Street up
there that was before I even asked I
like that that's good if the rest of you
can be like that perfect right hello
there and firstly that film is
incredible loved it I have questions
here for holiday and Richard from Maya
who's seven and
Rebecca who is three years old holiday
Rebecca would like to know what every
house it is why did you and the bad
mummy ripped Cinderella's beautiful
dress and Mayor would like to know did
you feel shy in those trousers holiday
we'll start with you I'll wait with
bated breath I feel like the stepmothers
kind of the leader of the pack and her
two daughters sort of follow in her wake
and and so I think they just the two
sisters just kind of want to do anything
to please mom but actually in my defense
there was a certain degree of
self-consciousness that you have to get
over em which is kind of when you first
have the toes on and you want to stand
with your back to the wall because you
feel expose but then that's the exposing
the fronts you want to turn around
enough you run to the mall but then your
backs exposed and but luckily although
all the guys we were in the same boat
together and so we all felt with still
use each other and actually once you get
on set those costumes madly feel really
masculine and they fit in with these
beautiful sets that Dante made and and
you kind of feel regal and it actually
gives you a confidence once you go over
there thank you gentlemen here hello
question for Kenneth and Sandi I don't
recall seeing a film as ravishing as
their since maybe Powell and Pressburger
well they kind of an influence and also
what were your featured influences for
this film well I mean I suddenly been
working on the film beef before I
arrived and so one of the one of the
joys was to have the first conversations
and as I recall anyway sandy laid out
for me sort of influences really across
the centuries first of all we as
stablished that i wanted a sort of blur
we could we could blur across the 19th
and 18th centuries and actually blur in
sorts in terms of shapes and things he
maybe even in the 20th century and what
was good to see it was that we both felt
that across worlds in which we we would
find the the way to make it all joined
up writing that that basically the
invitation was for Sandy's imagination
to go away and do the the amazing
amazing work that she's done to make it
all live in the Cinderella world but
really try and try and borrow from
wherever we felt a shape a color a
texture revealed revealed character and
and where sandy felt it it fitted into
into the whole picture we talked about
means one because a wonderful compliment
because I revere for him via those guys
a huge personal inspiration those that
particular partnership so from my point
of view that was the beginning of the
conversation yeah I'm gonna get again
really it's it was sort of for me it was
19th century all over the 19th century
with bits of 1940s and 1950s thrown in
like for the stepmother I was looking at
those sort of 1940s actresses like
Marlena Dietrich Joan Joan Crawford and
when they were in films made in the
1940s set in the 19th century how it
looks it's all a bit wrong I still see
the 1940s I really liked that element
for Kate and then for the sisters I kind
of went a decade higher and went to some
1950s versions of 19th century but then
in terms of the overall look I mean I
was thinking I was thinking actually
very much of them children's storybooks
and color and and being bright and
appealing to kids and being able to sort
of sum up a character with a color
straight away thank you and go first and
then we'll come down to the front so the
films got great receptions there firstly
congratulations
for that this is a question in two parts
I guess many for Lilly Kenneth and Sandy
there have been concerns raised so more
than once about the the corseting in
Cinderella's dress and how thought
eensy-teensy it makes her
waste the animated version has obviously
been a sort of a family favorite for
decades but parents have raised concerns
about issues of body image and the
impression the dress could leave on
their children the word about taking
their children to see it I guess the
first part is do you think those
concerns affair and the second part is
do they concern you at all I don't I
don't understand what the concerns are
actually I mean the lily does have a
small waist but then so do all the other
girls in the film all the girls in the
film are wearing corsets because that's
what you were with period clothes it
creates that the the silhouette for the
period holiday and Kate everyone else
had small waist too Lily's dress in
particular is an optical illusion I have
to say I mean the diameter of the skirt
is about two meters and then it's got
the width here and that really does make
the waist look smaller than it actually
is I mean one of the producers of the
film and I think it's it's gotten a lot
of attention but the funny thing is it's
kind of paying attention to the opposite
of the theme of the movie which is your
sense of beauty and your strength is
what's on the inside and and Sandy's
right I was there for all of the early
fittings I would look like I have a two
inch waist there's a giant set of
shoulders and there's butterflies and it
was customary for women to be coarse at
the time and there's two is it two miles
of fabric in the skirt so not only is an
optical illusion but I think it's so
interesting that the conversation has
been about the outside because this is a
movie where the real emphasis is on the
inside so as a mom I would really
encourage us to really because my
twelve-year-old daughter thought the
dress was really pretty but what she
took away from the film was the priority
of courage and kindness it's like the
questions that
you have from your daughter and I've had
friends kids and little boy Daniel he's
9 and he said it's amazing how you
promised your mom to be kind and good
and you remembered it and I just
that's the message why on earth are we
focusing on something so irrelevant you
know so then it's crashed and shall we
at lady in the front here please hey we
got your microphone they already know
let's get one to this lady here quickly
thank you that'd be great thanks hi
first of all congratulations on the film
and Cinderella is an iconic character
loved by generations touching on what
you've just sort of said in an era where
Disney are trying to reinvent the Disney
printers as it were how do you feel
Cinderella is stepping up to this modern
audience and what's it say to young
girls today well I think it's sort of
what we're talking about this strength
can come from within this dignified
strength and grace and and also that in
doing so she finds such joy and
happiness in her life regardless of her
situation even if it's just talking to
little gus-gus
but when I read the script I was sort of
bowled over by the fact that it was such
a truthful you know retelling of the
fairy tale without any tricks or twists
really but it felt really strong and a
girl I really wanted to play and felt
inspired playing her it feels as though
it's it's a different it's a different
kind of empowerment but I think it is
empowerment and I think that she makes
proactive choices even even if those
choices are sometimes to be thoughtful
and to be considerate so so it's a
question maybe of reconsidering the
notion of action and empowerment I'm
going to quote this would be weird at a
press conference but I'm going to
probably about to quote Gandhi right so
he says these these are quotes that were
at the the memorial service for the
great Richard Attenborough the other day
as some lines from Gandhi to to apply
and we discussed this this function
seems like a crazy thing to talk about
in relation to Cinderella but I think it
goes to the heart of the question Gandhi
said amongst many other things when I
despair I remember that all through
history the way of truth and love have
always won there have been tyrants and
murderers and for a time they can seem
invincible but in the end they always
fall think of it always and in relation
to why someone like perhaps Cinderella
doesn't do some of the things that some
people may expect her to do but does
them in a different way he may have some
light to throw on it in this way when he
says there are many causes I would die
for not one I would kill for an eye for
an eye only turns the whole world blind
and so we tried to find in an obviously
a much lighter way that attempts to you
know trip lightly over it that the sort
of the soul of the piece in in there but
the truth is something like Cinderella
has the possibility of encompassing that
amount of detail which we don't ever
need to spell out to a five-year-old
child it's just in the fabric of that
it's in the fabric of the doing of it
and so when people talk about the
sincerity of the movie it comes from
that that sort of that sort of place not
because we're trying to be holier than
now it's just that I believe it thank
you lady follow Gandhi mycoses of this
film looks visually stunning it means
got great palaces wonderful special
effects and a central character with
beautiful blond hair I just wonder if
your experiences making Thor influenced
this suitable or assisted you in you
know sort of knowing how to go about
making this obviously I've become
obsessive abut blonde hair
I think the I think trying to combine
worlds that have you know some
fantastical elements or maybe a
supernatural or a magical element with
human situations that are familiar to us
and where the motivations are
recognizable and situations the loss of
parents or challenges in love and human
dynamics also exist and that the two
don't sort of a jar in the wrong way but
might add up to something entertaining
are a sort of unusual combination of
things but they're very very friendly to
cinema where that kind of thing offers a
kind of visual immersion but still a
kind of emotional connection so they
have that that kind of connection I
guess thank you lady in the end please
thanks hi there wasn't any singing sadly
in this Cinderella with the cast still
have gone for the roles if there was
singing what was the reason why you
didn't have songs and what's your
favorite Disney songs but there is
actually singing at the end of the movie
Lilly sings a song as does Helena and we
have a little bit of lavender as well
you know the first the Disney animated
film was full of singing and lots of
lots of cat-and-mouse action and we we
have so much else going on in the movie
it felt that this felt the natural way
to go and we do have a sensational score
in my view anyway by Patrick Doyle so
there's a there's a strong a strong
musical element but I'm gonna be very
great trouble after this now they're all
going to say
okay goes this lady here in the third
room I don't like you
hi my questions are for Richard and I
know that you tone down your Scottish
accent and I was wondering if that was a
requirement for the role first of all
and second of all was there anything you
could take from your role as Robb Stark
to use in Cinderella such as maybe horse
riding or anything
well the accent I had obviously tied to
Derek and I don't know if I've been
Scottish it would have been a bit of a
statement of really Kingdom war as I
think so it was it was much better to do
that and and it worked a lot better I
think and in terms of Robb Stark I mean
yeah this horse trading in sword
fighting and stuff like that but I
suppose when the parallels with Prince
kit is this sense of responsibility
being thrust on you you've not asked for
and I think that's something I came to I
could relate to the two of them I think
it's a really strange unique position to
be n is royalty where where you have no
choice over over em what your duties are
thank you and leading the white shirt
and then we'll comfortably in the front
here hi I'm this question fairy she's
just following up on that did Prince
Charming not learn anything from Robb
Stark again he's married for the love
and not advantage it works out better
for the Prince I think he I think he
learns not to go into Westeros lady in
the green jumper in the front please
obviously believes in fairy godmothers
and magic do you guys believe in fairy
godmothers and magic can't help but
definitely believe that I like the fact
that the film allows for people that
maybe have a think about that we contain
our Magic's a little less than in other
accounts of the story to the central
single visit of the fairy godmother to
just allow for the idea that big you
know
different kind of internal
transformations can occur maybe without
that extra help but I think it's it's
very nice to think that occasionally the
universe in some form will come and help
us out one when we need it
Janet's got microphone there hi guys and
question two Lillian Richard if I may
and did you guys look in terms of
inspiration for your characters did you
look more towards the Noori imagination
from into the woods in terms of those
characters or was it more towards the
traditional side of the characters that
you notice when it came for inspiration
I've done I've seen into the woods look
into the woods for inspiration I mean
we'd already shot it I mean I know the
music I know I loved it but I tried to
draw from lots of different things I
mean I watch the animation a lot too
much or maybe but I read all different
versions of the fairy tales and and
tried to make it as rich as possible
where I drew from I think the tone of
the animation
yeah but the pendulum has two or three
scenes we don't even get to learn his
name and the animation so this was
something much more that mean can just
work together to try and create a young
man because we don't actually know the
princess you know we I think everyone's
got an idea of who he is but um but we
do actually have much to go on
thank you gentleman with a microphone
for Kenneth I thought it was absolutely
fantastic I thought it was pure magic is
a movie and what I wanted to ask was we
were mentioning earlier the influences
you know the lavishness of it's a
fabulous color and so on my particular
interest within that absolutely
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
boram's II and I wondered I mean the
leopard wore a piece Waterloo etc any
particular films with ballroom scenes
that especially influenced you to create
this glorious extravaganza particularly
congratulations on pronouncing
supercalifragilistic
you have practice that's very impressive
well along the way we talked about
various things and shared shared various
things and it was a conversation that
you know sandy and I would have along
with Dante Ferretti our production
designer in Harrisonburg Lucas our
cinematographer and extended across the
whole family of our sort of creative
team David Balfour our prop master etc
the kinds of films that were wonderful
to go and visit part from Powell and
Pressburger which we looked at again the
red shoes but we looked at Gone with the
Wind Wizard of Oz Visconti's the leopard
we also looked at Cyrano de Bergerac the
Rapinoe film Amelie actually for some
wonderful some wonderful camerawork and
it particularly kind of the swooping
shots that end up on close-ups of of our
heroine and were a rage of innocence is
a Scorsese movie that I particularly
loved for it's for what you were just
describing there the the immersion into
a world that you feel you can see and
taste and touch and smell so certainly
the we basically went to the classics
and but I hasten to add that Miss Powell
and mr. feretti and mr. zombie Lucas
were out there on their own in terms of
the in terms of forging our own
particular version of it because we were
allowed to as rich was saying in
relation to the relationship between the
king and their prince we were able to
inside this this this our classical
world nevertheless to forge our own
rules our own palace livery our own
color schemes there everything about it
we could we could rewrite so we were
inspired by those but felt also very
very free you know in our own work on it
congratulations again till what a
fantastic film my question is about the
ballroom was long actually it's about
the first dance i that was one of my
favorite moments in the film and i just
wanted to ask lily and richard what went
into preparation for that
can they always think there was three of
us in this relationship there was the
friends and Sunderland of the dress so
we had to kind of had to learn a new
technique of dance which was kind of
like skiing so you're doing kind of
destroy it and and we practiced for a
you know a couple of months before sandy
would let us anywhere near the actual
dress managed to kind of teed up a
couple of practice ones in the process
yeah and so it took a lot of work but it
was there was a couple of moments and I
I don't know whether this was planned
camp but we I sort of came in I went
down the steps and it sort of all
happened real time and I I walked in I
mean a real ballroom it's everything
feels real I mean it's just there and
and and I walked in and I meet the
prince and we danced and we didn't know
when you were gonna shout cut and you
ended up it was big wives and you did it
all the way through and no one knew
whether we were gonna stop or not and
this energy was building to the point
where I was just giggling I was dancing
I'm cooling and then and then we did it
all the way through till we ran out so
the work we then did meant that on the
day when those specific shots happened I
completely forgot it was only the dance
and it was one of my best experiences
I've ever had filming it was amazing
because of all the preparation that
originals both did the in the ballroom
itself I think it was a very special for
all of us who worked on it those days
and and that event the event of that
happening ie the two of them always just
the two of them always the whole dance
always with the entire ballroom watching
them and always with this sense that a
couple of things were at play there was
the whole lavishness of the world and
the sumptuous nature of it and yet we
were all overhearing this very sort of
intimate conversation and I swear to God
that despite all of that that as a group
the moment that Richards hand went on to
the small of Lily's back everybody in
the room went
including the boys that sequence is
always about that tiny thing and that
big thing and thank you very much for
being here this morning please a huge
one applause for our wonderful panelists
you